[Music]
welcome to the opening ceremony of super
United rapid and Blitz here in Zagreb
we're expecting the opening ceremony to
start soon with the presence of the
prime minister of Croatia as Ray
plankovic and former world champion Gary
Kasparov let's get to the action
[Music]
uh it is a pleasure to be here once
again to became a real tradition to come
to Zagreb to celebrate cheers over here
with the greatest players in the world I
I want to just to assure you that our
foundation will continue to bring the
chess to you they are chess lovers and
we'll try to bring the grand Masters
here to have a nice example for the kids
to try to educate them to give to them
the chance to become better people
there's a really quick work with them is
my friend in College Michigan and I
realized that it's the first big
tournament where one of the participants
in this case book HD was born after
retired from chess
that definitely fills me very old next
year we'll celebrate Justin's Library
again thank you
it was an amazing opening ceremony which
was broadcasted live on the national
television of Croatia many chess fans
came here and were happy to see all top
chess players and now it's time to get
back to the games
[Music]